- beam with a chance of becoming my best
restaurant all my semi-finalists will
need to be faultless got to take
criticism seriously I want to know if
they've corrected the problems I
identified earlier in the competition it
needed more seasoning to help me find
out
I've sent back in my team of secret
diners two of these restaurants will be
leaving the competition immediately
first the risk the Chop is my best
Italian Casimir from Bristol brothers
John Raine Peter are young and ambitious
and produce delicious food but early in
the competition I discovered at some of
the avant-garde dishes were confusing
diners I sent in a new secret diner food
expert Rob Allison to find out the boys
are reined in their wild experimentation
every time these boys create a dish
there's a huge jeopardy olives with star
anis doesn't sound like a perfect
combination but yet again they've pulled
it off next roast lamb sous-vide with
kidneys and pine nuts but what about the
addition of vacuum-packed cucumber to
the dish
we're taking off much the food of
Casimir is magical but some of the
dishes are still misfiring
it sounds really negative and it sounds
like yeah we could be possibly going him
there's that's the way it looks